this is the cold store at the pressure
drop brewery in tottenham in north
london it's one of more than 70
companies taking part in the largest
ever trial of the four day week
they'll receive 100 of their existing
pay but they'll only work 80 of the
hours four days or 32 hours a week but
they'll have to be 100
as productive as they were before
talking to the staff here they think
they can manage it by being smarter in
the way they work by planning better
whether they're in the office or on the
brewery floor and then they can deliver
productivity gains as the economist
would call it to the boss who believes
that he can deliver to his staff a
better quality of life across all sorts
of measures
now the organizers of the trial say
there are real benefits to the four day
week there is the quality of life there
is the reduction in stress and mental
health benefits as an environmental
benefit reducing commuting it will help
child care be shared across both people
who are working in a family so there are
lots of benefits but this is being done
at a time when the british economy is
facing huge pressures there is a
downturn brewing and there's great
pressure on companies and on workers to
become more productive british workers
are among the least productive in the g7
but they work some of the longest hours
this trial may finally help crack the
nut proving whether the british really
can be more productive